now there's a flip side of this which is
in a big design team what percentage of
people think their
their their uh their their plan or their
life's work is engineering versus design
inventing things so lots of companies
will reward you for
filing patents yes some many big
companies get stuck because to get
promoted you have to come up with
something new
and then what happens is everybody's
trying to do some random new thing
99 of which doesn't matter and the
basics get neglected
and or they get to there's a dichotomy
they think
like the cell library and the basic cad
tools you know or basic
you know software validation methods
that's simple stuff
you know they want to work on the
exciting stuff and then they
they spend lots of time trying to figure
out how to patent something
and that's mostly useless but the
breakthroughs aren't simple stuff
no no you no you have to do the simple
stuff really well
if you're building a building out of
bricks you want great bricks
so you go to two places to sell bricks
so one guy says yeah they're over there
in an
ugly pile and the other guy is like
lovingly tells you about the 50 kinds of
bricks and how hard they are and how
beautiful they are and
how square they are and you know which
one you can buy bricks from
which is going to make a better house so
you're talking about the craftsman
the person who understands bricks who
loves bricks who loves the variety
that's a good word you know good
engineering is great craftsmanship
and when you start thinking engineering
is about invention
and set up a system that rewards
invention
the craftsmanship gets neglected okay so
maybe one perspective is the theory the
science
over emphasizes invention and
engineering emphasizes craftsmanship and
therefore
like so if you it doesn't matter what
you do theory well everybody knows like
read the tech ranks they're always
talking about some breakthrough or
intervention
innovation and everybody thinks that's
the most important thing
but the number of innovative ideas is
actually relatively low
we need them right and innovation
creates a whole new opportunity
like when when some guy invented the
internet
right like that was a big thing the
million people that wrote software
against that we're mostly doing
engineering software writing
the elaboration of that idea was huge
you